il faut le dire il y a eu plusieurs
émissions qui ont quand même des XP
plein de contre vérités et en fait quand
il s'agit des rats on raconte tout et
n'importe quoi donc déjà je voudrais
quand même commencer
j'entends tout à fait que toi tu as
d'autres personnes on a la phobie des
rats et ça je l'entends c'est pas ça le
sujet le sujet il est pas là le sujet il
est déjà de dire que de rappeler
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire que les rats on
le sait il y a un consensus scientifique
sont des êtres sensibles il ressentent
la souffrance ils vendent des émotions
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé de
l'empathie il y a une étude qui a été
faite qui a montré que un rat sur deux
quand ils ont le choix entre manger du
chocolat ou sauver un congénère il sauve
leur congélère alors qu'ils adorent le
chocolat
ensuite ensuite sur les rails il y a
plein d'études sur le fait qu'ils ont
une conscience qui sont ultra
intelligents je rappelle qu'ils sont
utilisés pour détecter des
antipersonnelles il y a également ce
qu'on le sait pas mais quand on leur
fait des chats tout il rit alors on
l'entend pas parce que c'est un riz un
rire ultra sonore
exactement voilà tu vois tu peux faire
ça plutôt que les prendre à la jugulaire
[Rires]
appelez ça ensuite ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que aujourd'hui en fait les
méthodes qui sont utilisées elles sont à
la fois cruelles et inefficaces donc je
vais quand même vous parler de certaines
méthodes donc par exemple
l'empoisonnement massif qui est utilisé
notamment à Paris dans l'espace urbain
donc c'est des anticoagulants qui
provoquent des hémorragies internes donc
en fait on a des rats qui ont des
hémorragies sur plusieurs jours avant de
mourir et en plus c'est inefficace parce
qu'il devient de plus en plus résistants
donc en fait on est sur une course à
l'empoisonnement qui n'a ni que ni tête
après on pourrait parler aussi du piège
à colle donc c'est un test n'est pas du
tout sélectif
donc en fait c'est des plaques de colle
qu'on peut malheureusement acheter
n'importe où qu'on peut placer n'importe
où et à donner des animaux qui se
collent donc les rats peuvent mourir
d'épuisement de fin de soi qui peuvent
se démembrer c'est une technique qui est
interdite en Belgique
il y a enfin un pote à moi
[Applaudissements]
qui est le ministère de la recherche qui
met des moyens adaptés qui financent la
recherche pour trouver des méthodes qui
soient éthiques efficaces aux États-Unis
ça existe aux États-Unis il y a des
contrats qui sont utilisés à New York à
Los Angeles
qui sont en place notamment de
contraception orale et donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que il faut qu'on aille
sur des méthodes comme ça parce qu'en
fait tuer les rats sert à quoi je veux
dire après ils se reproduisent et ils se
remplacent tout ce qu'il faut c'est
limité la reproduction pourquoi on dit
on n'envoie plus qu'avant c'est quoi il
paraît que alors est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est le est-ce que c'est le
confinement il y a plein de gens qui
disent que le confinement aussi a fait
que les rats sont plus salés alors vas-y
bah vas-y parce que lui c'est bon il est
pas seulement je pense que les rats les
rails vont nous mettre à l'amende dans
pas longtemps parce que pendant trois
mois on leur a donné Paris ils sont
entraînés ils sont ils sont sortis ils
ont vu qu'ils ont pu peur de nous
l'erreur en fait ils en ont plus rien à
[ __ ] de nous on leur fait plus peur
donc ils sont sortis de plus en plus
pendant qu'en fait pendant le
confinement ils étaient là ils ont dit
tiens tu as vu il y a plus de bruit là
ils sont sortis ils ont dit tu as vu en
fait
c'est chez nous c'est
il faut arrêter de céder à l'hystérie
collective et doivent croître les peurs
irrationnelles sur les reins donc je
pense que c'est important de mettre un
peu de science donc là il y a le Museum
histoire naturelle à Paris qui fait une
grande étude sur les rats à Paris où on
va apprendre plein de choses alors sur
le nombre de rats on entend tout et
n'importe quoi alors je sais que Gilles
la dernière fois tu as évoqué des
nombres il faut arrêter il n'y a pas
d'études scientifiques sur le nombre de
rats à Paris
3,8 millions de rares Paris c'est
scientifique
en France c'est quoi par exemple à Paris
il paraît qu'il y a un rat et demi à
deux rares par personne alors ça c'est
c'est des chiffres je reprends ce qu'a
dit Christine de Nice qui est professeur
musium d'histoire naturelle tout à fait
fantaisiste
clairement aujourd'hui il y a aucune
étude scientifique qui a été fait pour
le nombre de rats donc tous les nombres
qui sont dits sont complètement comme ça
aléatoires souvent qui sont donnés par
les dératiseurs donc le musée naturel
est en train de réaliser une étude dans
deux trois ans on aura un nombre précis
je rappelle qu'à New York ça a été fait
il y a un statisticien qui a tenté le
nombre de rats à New York il y a 2
millions d'euros alors qu'il y a 9
millions d'habitants humains
[Applaudissements]
que
tu rejoins le groupe Philibert ça suffit
maintenant mais en fait c'est une
méthode très technique de la maman
s'il te plaît
[Rires]
c'est possible enfin je le dis c'est
possible de les compter et c'est en
cours
nous attaquer alors attends juste une
chose juste quand on dit il y en a de
plus en plus on peut pas le dire s'il y
a pas d'études s'il y a pas d'études
pour moi
[Musique]
bien avant le confinement qui est de
plus en plus de pique-nique dans les
espaces verts les poubelles on demande à
Anne Hidalgo
que les poubelles soient hermétiques
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
est-ce que je veux dire c'est que à
Paris dans l'espace urbain il y a 10 %
des poubelles qui ne sont pas
hermétiques vous l'avez vu c'est des
sacs plastiques donc c'est ça a été
refermer les poubelles il y avait des
trucs qui sautaient dans les poubelles
des bouteilles de gaz c'est aujourd'hui
il y a une stratégie de la ville de
Paris qui est de tout rendre les
poubelles hermétiques non seulement ils
sont pas hermétique mais ensuite elles
sont à ça du sol donc les rats peuvent y
accéder ensuite le déplacement des
populations il est dû aux travaux donc
il y a eu la Samaritaine il y a eu
Châtelet-les-Halles il y a eu le métro
le Grand Paris etc
alors sur ça c'est extrêmement rare
c'est extrêmement intéressant
mais pourquoi non mais pourquoi tu en
parles parce que c'est juste un pote un
jour essayer
sur la tête de ma mère il y avait un
rail il était sur la cuvette de CVC il
est en train de se faire quoi
sur la cuvette comme un strain de son
fils
j'ai toujours
les images que tu as montré là c'est
quoi c'est l'état du canal exactement
tout le monde est choqué par le rakinage
moi ce qui me choque de déchets qu'il y
a dans les rues qui a dans le canal mais
c'est ça qui est plus chaud en vrai en
vrai là tu as raison sur un truc c'est
que la cause c'est ça et c'est voilà
donc c'est ce que tu voulais dire tout à
fait donc en ce moment les villes sont
de plus en plus sales comment ça se fait
oui tout à fait ben il y a le fait qu'on
jette n'importe où n'importe comment et
on a on a eu un rendez-vous avec
l'adjointe à la propreté avec son
cabinet de Anne Hidalgo on a demandé que
les poubelles soient relevées
systématiquement le soir et pas le matin
parce qu'en fait il y a des gardiens qui
peuvent sortir les poubelles le soir et
elle reste toute la nuit dehors et les
gens mettent des déchets au pied des
poubelles etc donc la gestion des
déchets et en effet fondamental si on
veut limiter le nombre de répressions
les rats n'ont plus peur des humains non
mais ça c'est n'importe quoi
je vais y répondre
la possibilité il fuit enfin je veux
dire non si il fuit dans la possibilité
[Applaudissements]
avec des rats de 45 kilos
bonjour
Siri juste pardon pour rebondir sur ce
que dit Amandine chaque année en France
il y a beaucoup plus de morts de morsure
de chien que de morsure de rat il y a
10000 morceaux de chiens par si on prend
si on prend le critère de la dangerosité
de l'animal ça veut dire quoi parce
qu'il y a une morsure de chien on
élimine tous les chiens non non non
exactement les rats est-ce qu'il faut
pas essayer de réguler de faire une
patrouille il faut limiter la
reproduction
n'est pas la solution
les méthodes létale ne marche pas
exactement ce n'est pas efficace on est
à la troisième voilà il faut limiter la
reproduction donc c'est pour ça que je
redis il y a des méthodes contraceptives
qui existent aux États-Unis c'est
scandaleux que ça n'existe pas en France
donc la recherche doit investir
massivement là-dessus et on veut ces
méthodes nous on a demandé
je ne sais pas je ne l'aurais pas
demandé
Amandine franchement votre propos est
très intéressant mais c'est vrai par
certaines contreérités vous
l'affaiblissez vous dites il y a pas
trois il y a 3,8 millions de dollars
c'est faux vous dites les rats ne sont
pas plus agressifs qu'avant mais tout le
monde constate que c'est sûr
même dans leurs yeux on voit le délire
une odeur soyons sérieux c'est une
réalité
je vais vous le dire je vais vous le
dire et je suis désolé de vous le dire
mais les rats ne sont pas responsables
de tous les mots cette planète
excusez-moi attention
histoire de Liverpool donc que vous avez
dit ok c'est important il faut qu'on en
parle donc déjà premièrement ce qu'il
faut dire donc c'est que les morsures
sont extrêmement rares et c'est pour ça
que vous en parlez c'est pour ça que
vous faites des blagues c'est que c'est
rarissime comme l'a dit Hugo il y a 10
000 morts sur de chien par an est-ce
qu'on va vous mettre à tirer tous les
chiens j'ai pas fini j'ai pas fini
excuse-moi juste pour dire en fait que
la question de la présence des rats chez
les particuliers c'est la question du
logement insalubre et c'est ça le
véritable scandale il faut rénover les
immeubles et
une boutique où je reçois les rats j'ai
envie d'appeler bon débarras
ratatouille
aujourd'hui parce que attends 2 minutes
parce que il y a un mec qui va arriver
c'est Eric je vous parle et lui il est
pas d'accord avec toi il pense que les
rats sont de plus en plus dangereux non
mais on entend de plus en plus
d'histoires
Amandine ce qui est agaçant c'est que
vous êtes un peu comme la politique je
parle pas des solutions mais vous vous
êtes dans le déni il y a pas plus de
rack avant si pardon ça fait 40 ans que
j'habite Paris je les vois partout
on les voit plus donc ils ont moins peur
pardon ils ont moins peur qu'il était
très facile effectivement
de pas on a tous un ennemi qui
maintenant était mort du passé de nier
juste évident
un homme meurt chez lui après la morsure
d'un rat ça supporte plein de contre
Paris Habitat
c'est un HLM avec un logement totalement
saluent avec une personne qui avait des
problèmes de système immunitaire et
évidemment que quand on est mordu par
n'importe quel animal évidemment que il
faut le montrer
tous les jours des morsures de rats
évidemment
tu es devenu un ringard
aujourd'hui il y a deux trucs ça fait du
placard ou tu as été mordu par hasard
j'ai fait deux ans de placard moi
j'étais mordu par deux rat tu vois et
l'autre respect
Amandine j'écoute votre discours depuis
tout à l'heure et il est il est très
bien mais vous
occupez totalement le fait que les rats
sont vecteurs de maladies et je suis
bien placé pour en parler en 2017 j'ai
eu la leptospirose j'ai eu quatre
semaines d'hospitalisation j'ai eu euh
honnêtement la létalité c'est 20% sur la
leptospirose et 15 sur ça qu'est-ce que
vous voulez faire parce que j'ai failli
crever moi mais quand je vois les rats
honnêtement moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
des raquettes je vois que moi j'ai
failli crever Hugo disait tout à l'heure
que on sauve nos espèces avant de sauver
les autres moi les rats honnêtement
quand je vois que moi j'ai failli mourir
à cause des rats à cause de la
leptospirose qu'est-ce que vous voulez
faire contre la leptospirose bah alors
c'est extrêmement simple j'allais tout
aussi rose en effet c'est la seule
maladie qui pourrait être un problème de
santé publique qui pourrait être un
problème public et ce qui rendent parce
que ça croit depuis les années quand
même en effet alors pourquoi ça croit
déjà c'est une maladie qui se transmet
par l'urine donc il faut avoir en
contact direct avec l'urine
mais c'est important ça peut être
transmise par d'autres animaux que les
rats il y a un vaccin il y a un
traitement sur la lithospirose on va
recevoir Éric jouffart qui lui contre le
rail combat le rat voilà depuis des
années on va voir une vidéo juste même
si les professionnels sont divisés sur
la question les rongeurs sont nettement
plus visibles qu'on leur terrier sont
inondés vous savez ça c'est vrai
regardez on vous a fait une petite
compile de tous les rack on peut voir
quand il pleut Éric jouffrin nous
rejoint c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors Amandine merci Eric choufard
d'être venu nous rejoindre Castaldi
avait une question intéressante pour
tous les deux d'ailleurs parce que il
est venu me la dire à la pub il est bien
meilleur à la pub que
alors oui
très bien mais est-ce que ils sont
utiles à quelque chose dans une ville
oui justement il y a les le service donc
de la propreté à Paris qui explique en
fait qui mange énormément de déchets et
que sans les rats à Paris les égouts
seraient bouchés donc il faut il faut
aussi en tenir une autre solution
justement mais non mais ce qu'il faut
c'est trouver des solutions pour limiter
la reproduction enfin c'est ça qui est
sérieux aujourd'hui
est-ce que je dis c'est que alors je
redis que tous les animaux sont
susceptibles de transmettre des maladies
c'est une réalité tous les animaux que
sur la question des rats les morsures
sont exceptionnelles
parce que le logement est insalubre et
qu'il faut régler cette culture et que
sur la question des morsures il y a des
morsures de chien il y a des morsures de
plats animaux et donc tout morsure doit
être montré à médecin doit désinfecter
et ça c'est ça
budget comme ça pour un immeuble comme
ça d'un coup ça marchera pas on arrive
franchement
Eric vous vous combattez les reins ouais
c'est combien de temps ça en février
prochain ça fera à peu près 8 mois
d'accord 8 ans
c'est moi vous renvoie dehors
ça fait 8 jours ça fait 8 heures
monsieur d'accord précise excusez-moi
que c'est parti d'une passion que
j'avais pour ces bêtes qui a la base
effectivement en fait voilà la base à la
base donc à la base vous aviez pas de de
comme voilà elle n'avait pas peur des
rares à la base non parce que je les ai
beaucoup moins côtoyé mais même ils
étaient là depuis même avant la création
de l'oeuvre c'est ce qui a tout créé
mais malheureusement voilà c'est une
passion qui aujourd'hui j'ai pas peur de
le dire et devenu une réelle menace pour
l'homme et pour l'humanité
menace
il faut arrêter de dire n'importe quoi
enfin
c'est le mien donc ça fait 8 ans que je
le fais je me suis placé
encore une fois la question n'est pas de
dire il n'y a pas de problème enfin moi
je dis pas ça moi ce que je dis c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour rien vous ce
problème de manière éthique et efficace
en quoi consiste votre métier alors la
b2r c'est la brigade des répressions de
rares c'est à dire
par des rails nous appellent et nous on
arrive et on les a dit exactement ah
d'accord
[Rires]
ah non j'ai une question
moi est-ce que sérieusement c'est
efficace en fait vous les tuer ensuite
se reproduisent et ensuite on dit c'est
pareil
si c'est pas efficace eux ils sont très
chassez vous les tuer comment expliquer
vous les chassez vous le regulez vous
dites voilà exactement donc voilà je
peux pas permettre de dire que je
connais tout surtout par contre je
connais très bien les rats parce que
vous les connaissez par cœur je les
connaissais parc je l'ai je les connais
par cœur effectivement et vous savez qui
souffre mais évidemment que je sais
qu'il souffre mais c'est parce qu'il
souffre qui font du mal justement donc
évidemment il faut essayer de trouver un
moyen de régler cette souffrance mais
non on n'a pas le temps et on peut pas
forcément retrouver un moyen de régler
cette souffrance je pense qu'il faut des
personnes qui s'en occupent correctement
mais nous c'est pas notre métier nous on
est là pour débarrasser les rats des
personnes qui en souffrent exactement
qui qui survivent en fait et qui se
reproduisent donc on va continuer comme
ça combien de temps on est à la
troisième génération
sur quelque chose je crois voilà il y a
pas grand chose pour voir si ah vous
dites qu'il y a pas de chiffres mais
c'est pas vrai il faut savoir aussi il y
a 2,2 millions de rats uniquement
scientifique c'est faux le misère me le
dit c'est comment
vous êtes à la télé ou pas il y a des
gens qui vous faites ça parce que vous
c'est votre métier de toi
à Paris par exemple seulement
intra-muros il y a 2,25
je vous écoute est-ce que les rats sont
de plus en plus agressifs bien sûr que
les races sont de plus en plus agressifs
et même pour être franc il y a une
espèce de rat bien en particulier bien
particulièrement qui elle de plus en
plus agressive et ça c'est du et
évidemment aussi à cause du
réchauffement climatique immigre du
Bengal occidental pour arriver à l'ouest
de l'Europe et représente 10 % de la
population de France pardon ils viennent
comment ils viennent très bien
je vais là-bas j'ai vu l'heure anodo
[Applaudissements]
qui est formidable en plus alors et donc
excusez-moi
c'est des rat donc ils ont migré donc en
Europe occidentale et représente 10 à
20% de la population de l'Île-de-France
faut se rendre compte de ce que c'est 10
à 20%. c'est vous savez ce chiffre mais
je le sais parce que on a des personnes
qui étudient aussi avec nous ils vont
prendre leur sauce inférieurs
extrêmement puissant ils ont des membres
extrêmement puissant parce que la
plupart ils vont attaquer les membres
inférieurs c'est à dire ils vont ils
vont attaquer le chevet ou les mollets
mais comme vous l'avez dit hier il y a
des rats aussi qui sont capables de
sauter et qui attaquent plus haut et
nous on a recensé des attaques qui ont
été faites au plexus et qui ont été
faites aussi à la carotine et ça ça a
été fait dans le 18e arrondissement par
exemple et pourquoi ils arrivent ils se
regroupent toujours ensemble ils sont
toujours ensemble ils sont regroupent
toujours ensemble parce qu'ils ont les
membres inférieurs extrêmement puissants
il faut savoir qu'ils sont capables de
faire des sauts à plus de 2 mètres
c'est
intervention Portugal j'ai fait une
intervention alors celle-là c'est la
plus folle que j'ai pu faire mais enfin
c'est pas des blagues ils sont
réellement sur entraîner c'est comme si
ils avaient des enfants de combat pour
pour pouvoir le faire mais donc moi j'ai
été sollicité ça a été une fois assez
rare j'ai été sollicité au Portugal et
avant de dire ça je me permets de dire
que 67 % d'entre eux
ils appelaient que le Bushido est-ce que
vous savez
non mais franchement il y a des chiffres
qui sont balancés
d'écouter
en bas voilà non mais c'est pas sérieux
le boucher dos c'est ça va faire sourire
mais c'est un art martial qui est très
connu
connu chez les rats
c'est le boucher d'eau alors et donc et
ils sont ils sont réellement organisés
c'est-à-dire que si ils se mettent à
trois ou quatre sur une personne non
mais c'est ça vous fait rire mais si ça
vous arrive je vous garantis que vous
allez pas rire demandez aux personnes
cette intervention Portugal alors ils
m'ont appelé c'est très rare ça a duré 5
heures normalement ça me prend une heure
pour attraper euh 5h c'est un rat qui
maîtrisait le Muay Thaï
je comprends que c'est lucratif de tuer
les rats mais sérieusement si on peut
mettre l'histoire
qui se rapprochaient celui de l'être
humain d'accord étant donné qu'il y
avait les toutes les pattes engagées
non non une chose à savoir qui est la
plus importante c'est-à-dire c'est que
si ce mec à quatre ou cinq sur une
personne qui sont capables
en Asie il faut des combats et je mets
pas dit le nom de cette race ça
s'appelle des punjas
en Asie en Asie il faut s'il vous plaît
monsieur
en Asie ils font des combats entre les
poules jaunes justement et le champion
du monde entier tradition 235 victoires
à son actif
par exemple est-ce que vous avez un
spécimal alors voilà moi j'ai je pars
bien spécialiste j'ai ramené un
spécimens
bien sûr qui est vivant qui a été
travaillé qui a été étudié et qui est
complètement est-ce qu'il s'entraîne
combien d'heures par jour
c'est pas des entraînements mais disons
que nous on lui laisse le quartier libre
3-4 heures par jour d'accord on va
est-ce qu'on peut faire rentrer
s'il vous plaît faut vraiment
d'accord ok pour de vrai ok ok
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il s'appelle il s'appelle
Steven
et je vais donner le même prénom que mon
propre fils je voudrais qu'on
applaudisse très fort tigradement
[Applaudissements]
ok c'est bon
Amandine j'ai eu un fou rire mais
Amandine elle est incroyable
franchement
Amandine en tout cas c'est très
intéressant ce que tu nous as dit et
franchement tu nous as fait réfléchir tu
vois franchement je vous ai juste dit en
dernière chose c'est que voilà
aujourd'hui un concession scientifique
sur le fait que les rats souffrent ne
faisant pas comme si on ne le savait pas
quoi voilà très bien et ensuite je lance
un dernier appel s'il te plaît
collectif avec une association
donc on lui a fait un courrier collectif
normalement il devrait être projeté avec
une dizaine d'associations dans la SPA
et le 114 et tout pour lui demander de
créer un groupe de travail sur des
méthodes non létales éthiques et
efficaces et de les mettre en place on
n'a jamais eu de réponse donc est-ce
qu'elle pourrait au moins nous répondre
merci beaucoup